megan is with us in Bakersfield
California hi Megan how are you I'm
doing real better than I deserve
how can I help okay so one I just have
like a pretty weird personality so I
might get all crazy here but we're on
the tail end of baby step two we only
have like $3,600 me on the one bill and
my husband is finishing the last of his
prerequisites to start nursing school
and we plan on just bankrolling that the
whole way through with help from parents
and we don't want to take out loans good
so I am more of like a future planner
like I don't like to think just like
where we're gonna be in five years like
I'm thinking more about the mortgage
when my husband graduates because a lot
of a much larger income and I have heard
a lot about like prepaid interest or
prepaid principal and they don't really
understand how that works like I was
watching the pill method and then he was
talking about taking out loans and I was
like this guy's and not listening to it
but that's kind of where I was that was
how do principle payments work yeah it
makes it sound like there's some kind of
a magic to it it there's nothing magic
to it at all you take the interest rate
of your mortgage and you multiply it or
divide it by 12
okay and you multiply that times the
outstanding balance that month that is
the interest charged that month does
that make sense
mm-hmm and the rest of your payment goes
towards principle and so let's just make
up some easy numbers let's say 6%
interest rate which would be very well
issues 3% interest rate okay
that's current that's a quarter of a
percent 0.25 per month if you divide
three percent by 12 okay you'll get a
quarter of a percent per month and it
and so if you had a hundred thousand
dollar loan just to make the numbers
real round just because it's a good it's
a good lesson to walk through you'd say
0.025 is your
oops I did that it's point zero two five
still not doing that right a hundred
thousand but I put too many things in
the calculator one time point oh no two
five there we go
okay there we go two hundred bucks I
should be able to do that in my head
alright anyway two hundred fifty dollars
of your payment that month if you have a
hundred thousand dollar balance that
three percent would go towards interest
right okay now let's say your payment
was three hundred and fifty dollars
it wouldn't be let's say it's four
hundred and fifty dollars okay okay and
then so 250 went to interest the other
two hundred dollars would pay the
$100,000 does that make sense yeah the
next month your interest is calculated
on ninety eight thousand eight hundred
dollars at a quarter and so instead of
being two hundred fifty dollars I make
up a number let's say it's two hundred
forty-seven dollars okay but your
payment your payment is still four
hundred dollars but a little bit less
when to interest so a little bit more
goes to principle so instead of paying
two hundred dollars towards principal
the next month in our example it might
be two hundred and three dollars you
follow me okay so if every time you pay
principal that makes your next payment
more of it go towards principal less
towards interest so it's like say for
example I was gifted a thousand dollars
for I don't know just being amazing and
somebody and we went and put that on the
principal yes would that change our
payment the next month
no a mint stays the same it changes the
amount of interest would go down because
you're gonna be charged interest on a
thousand dollars less you're not paying
interest on that thousand dollars
anymore okay and so it would cause your
your payment would stay exactly the same
but more of your payment would go
towards principal oh you don't have as
high an interest charge because you
don't have as high a balance your
interest is calculated on the balance
each month you pay your interest rate
only on what's outstanding so if you
throw 10,000 bucks at a mortgage you
don't pay interest the next month on
that $10,000 it saves you the interest
on that $10,000 your payment stays the
same so a lot more of your payment would
then go towards principal the following
month than it did before so that's why
sometimes people say oh you know I don't
I don't wanna I've already paid all the
interest so I don't want to pay my
mortgage off because I don't have
already paid all the interest upfront no
you didn't you only pay interest on
what's outstanding and once you've paid
on the mortgage for years and years and
years and you paid the principal down
your payment is still the same much much
more of your payment goes towards
principal after 15 years and a 30-year
mortgage then at the 28th year of a
30-year mortgage exactly okay yeah this
is the kind of stuff that they should
teach in high school because nobody
taught me that yeah that's exactly right
well good news is 36 percent of the high
schools in America now carry a Dave
Ramsey high school curriculum called
foundations and personal finance so
we've got a little over a third of them
but we got the other 2/3 to go so but
you're exactly right
that's called a simple interest
calculation that I just walked through
with you but that's how any mortgage is
calculated have you ever seen the tables
printed out on a mortgage payment where
it shows the columns and shows your
payment it shows how much it's going to
interest how much it's going to
principal and who you slide your finger
down your down the page you're like wow
a whole lot more after paying you know
120 payments paying 10 years a whole lot
more of its going towards principal and
an interest you follow me yeah if you've
ever seen that so what happens is if you
want to do this easy without having to
do the raw math if you pay $10,000 on
your balance you just slide your finger
down the outstanding balance and your
own payment number 37 when you did it
then you pay $10,000 then you're gonna
drop down it might be looking more like
payment number 61 there's gonna be your
next payment so you're just knocking out
chunks of payments it's gonna be
calculated like payments 61
whatever wherever the balance is closest
to the New Balance after you paid your
10,000 bucks down so it's an item that
really helps a lot I was super worried
about it because I really want to get it
paid off within like 10 years after he
graduates
yeah that's why throwing money at the
mortgage early and often when you get to
baby step 6 is so important if you but
it's also why you don't need to do more
than once a month because they only
recalculate once a month the payments
are monthly payments and so if you send
for payments in a month it doesn't
change the math at all now they all go
towards principal but you might as well
just send one check and so I've seen
these groups with these supposed systems
that they've gotten all this BS where
you just start sending payments and you
don't want it you want to send one a
week and now it doesn't work because the
calculation is done once a month it is
1/12 of the interest the annual interest
rate per month it is not a daily or a
weekly calculation on mortgages now some
credit cards are calculated daily and
some are calculated twice or three times
or four times a month so they're a
little different but anything that's
calculated once a month paying on it
more than once a month does not change
the math do you understand yeah cool
it's good to talk to you thank you for
calling you that's a good question